three
um
push real hey welcome to the show
push it real good that's right it's
us well because you're real good hey
turn turn girl paula what he's saying
turned good old paul up hey everyone
do you like listening to a show
where we have audio issues right off
the bat and can you hear me
now
now you have a hot take on
that curator sweet guy and whenever
i take money from this company and
this company and i don't give a
fuck i don't give a fuck either
because judas i'm on record with that
as well i was the first time
i saw that commercial i was horrible
i was discussed here's what i thought
who cares who you are and what
you're doing i don't care if you
told me you
we're always with sprint i would've been
like yeah i guess can you hear
me now with sprinting i don't know
he didn't need to explain who you
are just get them i don't know
i think he could star in movies
but he just went for like above
the above the title in movies after
this same mayor and paul the sprint
guy and in kung fu panda e
kung fu screen
we're gonna skip day you know thinking
oh i'm gonna meet many years until
that happens something you don't think he'd
be on camera you think it's just
like he's got such a great voice
why wouldn't need to know he'll be
real and the rest of the movies
he's wandering around the country and a
world he's come to kind of ah
i'm paul
yeah so you know way more about
it i made a lot of attention
to this guy
you did you get a dossier when
you saw that he switched over you're
like i want to strength and networth
i went to paul feig
paul spring guy feet yeah
i bet that there's something out there
some system kind of looking up right
now which isn't in converse if you're
someone who's in defeat god bless you
but what is there about this sneeze
what is it about feet that people
like i don't know and i i
actually i was recently on my friend's
podcast it's called unbearable it's like about
um bears like gay guys and one
of the guys told a story about
how he met a guy who wanted
him to put his shoe up his
up the other guy's butt and show
it with
fresh converse to put on wo put
it up his butt you mean the
converse like what i were on comedy
bang bang for brinks mat and that's
how he interesting is like these represent
yeah awesome and i would warn high-tops
just get eighteen yeah i ever tell
you about the show that i was
in called high-tops no tell me about
it now my first em
prov team in chicago was called red
hot hi tom really yeah what's your
this was a christian musical that i
was in when i was fifteen oh
boy yeah look at you go and
those high tops and it was all
about ah cool jesus yeah it was
like a hike it was like a
high school ah and everyone who's cool
we're high tops this is nice
eight you got that tracks that sucks
and i was i was the nerd
what you have to wear your old
sharpies
wow you got me
bitch you fucking got me
they're like you i got this part
because of you but you already war
oh well we'll we will thank you
for coming in we have cast apart
you got it to be called what
you already bore
when you're a child oh wait it
was it was with heck it was
with a catholic diocese i yes yea
yeah they put it on but it
was a christian musical but there's a
lot of overlap with both of those
um and but it was it was
my first experience with um they're one
of the guys in the show they
thought was acting out so they
asked him to stay after a rehearsal
and then they all laid hands on
him and prayed over hey wait
they panned him because he was being
rambunctious yeah he was these were catholics
these are catholics yeah wow it was
strange i think there was i think
it was the catholic diocese was putting
it on but then there were christians
involved rose but i'd never seen nor
heard of that before of people like
you he was like it was cr
crazy man i like they asked me
to stay after and then they were
like you're acting you know really disobedient
lean and so we're all gonna pray
over you and and put our hands
on you i don't wanna do it
yeah he's just threatened with suspension well
it wasn't yeah because it was the
summer it was like a summer program
oh yeah i don't know it was
crazy it made him mow the lawn
yeah a lot of ideas now i
worry i wish i'd been there that's
what i've used a time machine for
to go back and help that guy
it was the first time i'd ever
heard of a camel toe because you
saw him
because we we one of the teachers
ah who was directing the player helping
out with the play i guess had
one one day never got and everyone
was like a woman yeah and so
it became a chuckle otherwise it became
a catchphrase of check out the sketch
check out the cd on the teach
became like a thing we would say
now the first time you heard it
did you say what does that mean
or did you pretend you already knew
he was one of those things it
was a lot like i remember when
i was twelve or thirty was just
a parent like c t god i
know exactly what you're doing when i
was twelve or thirteen everyone started talking
about bush they're like oh man ah
check out her bush or whatever nigerian
counter book and i didn't know what
that was and i assumed it was
when you would go in the bushes
with a girl and she would like
show you her privates or something yeah
that makes sense so for a year
i was like huh yeah bush this
was like what nineteen ninety nine boo
i'd like to bush her
but ctf pick but i think they
explained what a camel toe was i
think i know what it is it's
concussions but of course you know what
you don't know now
i'll tell ya do oh i know
well yeah pulser pant shot per per
se
do women have the same thing the
lore and where it's looking at do
you have do you have ah certain
slang words about yeah we say look
at that m k
snuggle what about yourself i mean about
dude yeah that's it no no dude
it is the best that camel toe
for a man with your balls on
a separate sheet pan the balls no
i'm not looking for that but if
my eyes see and i'm gonna call
you loudly do you think some people
are looking for it i think some
people are trying to get people to
look for it and you know what
you think some people are wearing and
wear things to show to tax too
high yeah yeah we know who
name them this no this is the
forum no i'm scared
i never liked anyone
what's the weirdest thing you're into lore
ah tears with something okay this is
weird but um okay so you know
when a guy's dick is like splitting
happen to meet on its too yeah
yeah you got your peels i loved
that puts the best
i'm really good at prince edward splits
down the middle i believe so at
least down the middle but i got
much bad
no i mean that's what well i
thought it's it's a piercing in your
dick hole but it makes a separation
two p two streams i mean i've
seen a picture of that i don't
know about the peeing part i have
seen that streams yeah i heard about
me and how well love on what
such love sure savion glover savion glover
there was a tap remember yeah yeah
yeah and an early version because we
talked about prince albert
yeah totally strange episode episode ten they
just stopped tapping and talked about splitting
their penises there's a lot of complaints
translating the taps
okay so the podcast is just the
sound of people tap tapping but in
morse code
let's get going
you are you're full of beans today
i'm failing
you have your usual you have a
little snack and a little snack and
it was a ten jello has a
little it's a little halo a little
halo um i do have something i
want to talk about ah okay it's
not serious i just have us record
a podcast and talk about family meeting
you guys seen your ebay nansen
you thought right yeah so you end
up seeing i haven't seen it he
was invited but i was invited that
i'd want to go to bed but
i um i've been waiting to to
listen to anything from it because i
just wanted to see it and i
heard that so good i was like
i don't wanna know anything about i
just want to go in but i
don't know when it's gonna happen and
i i saw ben platt on the
grammys and i was like i just
have to listen to it's not
like hamilton though we're young and get
a sense of what the story know
so i don't really i've pieced together
some parts of the story but i
don't really know but the songs are
so good anyway because i was told
don't listen to it without seeing it
but then i just was like i
just wanna know and i would say
you can listen to without seeing it
this is what you want to talk
to us huh
i want first of all i think
the same but when you saw it
yeah right utah it's no it's amazing
i would i would it was to
the extent that we didn't know who
could replace him that's what i because
i thought once i missed him i
was like well no no when am
i gonna see it's gonna be so
long whatever and the music has made
me like cry so much without any
contests
like i would imagine that whoever replaced
him is great in it but ah
i'm sure i mean yeah of course
that's always singers are so impressive yeah
it's always the thing when a show
starts and then the person that originates
throws like well there's no point i
mean who's ever going to be as
good as rad but it's like these
things run forever and it's like of
course a bunch of great people are
gonna be there get somebody sting
but it's the end i just i've
never seen him anyone do what he
does he's so amazing i've just heard
him and random things should be like
somersaults he splits his penis down the
middle i got to see de um
and i was thinking yesterday as i
was listening to it how amazing broadway
singers are and like how talented there
and i was thinking about christine ebersole
oooooh i saw warpaint this summer and
then it got to my audition that
i was going to and she was
there and i got to meet her
whoa i was just thinking of you
and then of course i thought that
sounded so fake but i still did
it and you guys are auditioning for
the support yeah that was the joke
she shimon
i've just like her but i love
her and she's also from one of
my favorite movies of all time which
is i didn't mention because i don't
know how she would feel about it
but my girl too
girl was so i've never even seen
when they go to l a when
i was return of the bees i
loved it because she goes to l
a to try to learn about her
dead mom this is clumsy yeah and
it's just like a really cool seventy
s l a vibe in the whole
movie i just loved it so much
and because you want to move to
la
i don't know i just thought it
was really cool and like the music
was so cool and i had the
soundtrack and it was like when you
moved to la what was it oh
yeah this is what i thought it
would be from the movies or is
um it was interesting because it was
so i had never really been here
i only visited one time and my
perception of it was so based on
like tv and movies and i
just even like living in a warm
climate was weird to me and i
think it's really weird when you see
something in the movies that pretends like
all of l a is in the
same spot like right i just watched
something in their data was like new
or i'm like they're pretending to just
get from venice yeah for like even
on like a football game if it's
if it's downtown at the coliseum or
whatever they'll they'll coming back from a
commercial show
show like the santa monica pier like
we're here in l a it's like
that is out an hour away money
like when i watch a football game
this is what tv does is like
so there they start one goalpost and
then they act like the other goalpost
is just like the distance of a
football field away yeah it's like so
much further i used to live in
a football field yeah and so
how was that it was cold drafty
draftee especially because teen lot of times
whip and noisy there wasn't a dome
there wasn't a no
ah what was where did you live
when you first north hollywood haha i
got a little apartment but it was
amazing because i was moving from new
york where i was living in a
two bedroom with a couple and it
was probably like no joke like six
hundred square feet i don't i mean
probably the entire yeah it was tiny
it was just two
bedrooms in a small space between the
two of them with like a fridge
um and it was bad so when
i got here and i could pay
so much less for like i got
like you know was a shitty apartment
but like it was nine hundred bucks
for a one bedroom and i was
paying seven hundred for my room and
this shitty place and it would that
was amazing to me i was like
this is nice because the balcony was
the first time
living alone no i wasn't living alone
i was living my boyfriend at the
time oh it's four hundred fifty bucks
really ah when i when i moved
to l a i didn't know anyone
i knew like i found out that
i knew one person when i'm when
i moved to our guy an old
friend mine that i'd lost touch with
and then found out that he was
here after i moved here
and i was like staying on couches
of people that i didn't know that
well and it was very uncomfortable and
you're the inspiration for crashing yeah yeah
and i'm the inspiration for his wife
i say i say take my story
just got story and take it take
it we're not gonna do anything with
no one wants to hear this story
turns out i was wrong
um i said so this friend of
mine brian
said ham leaving l i'm gonna move
back to philly bryan do we know
him no you don't want to say
his name you don't have to you
don't i don't have to and i
won't happen
he said you can come crash with
me and then you can take over
my apartment because i'm moving back to
philly i was like great and he
had this building it's the ones right
around the corner yeah right right i
was gonna ask it's the comedy oh
yeah i'm sorry i lived over here
i did i used to cheese sorry
scott i'm trying to see your face
better
no i'm a beautiful boy and you
put two microphones review yeah give a
shit about yeah
so very hurt i crush o'brien's couch
bryan was staying in this in this
one bedroom apartment um with his girlfriend
and i was sleeping on the couch
with a murphy bed
you're getting ahead of yourself sorry my
dear boy please can tell right the
movie the movie have what's going on
with a mentor
so brian did not move back to
philadelphia for another i wanna say for
five months oh so is the three
of us in this one bedroom apartment
and when i first i guess moved
in which i didn't realize i was
moving in the girlfriend was so nice
to me and like this would be
great for brian you know to have
you around have a friend around and
then by the end of it it
was like she would walk in the
door and if i was in the
apartment she would roll her eyes awe
at the sight of me um it's
so hard to have someone a so
of course i'm like i know this
is the worst yeah you know i
know this is you know but but
you just remind me he it took
you're the worst took so long for
him my story that coven
show your the weight maybe wait what's
this podcast i don't know yet this
podcast or the world what you made
it weird oh yeah and you're the
worst as a show right brian stuck
around for so long that i another
apartment opened up in that building and
i took that apartment and that was
one within and they still were annoy
you every day
this is just her he was always
happy to say had someone come visit
me and there's a chance to listen
to this and i don't think i
care he was someone i didn't really
i was never that close with but
he wanted to he was coming to
l a and needed a place to
stay and i i'd moved there and
whenever so i said yeah i had
a couch and he came and stayed
and then like didn't
do anything on his trip to l
a to the point where i mean
i made him like a frozen pizza
or something and he was like picking
off all the topics like annoying
and then then he was like watching
harry potter on tv like all day
one day i was like what are
you he was just visiting and then
i was like having friends over to
work on something and i thought i'd
be like obvious like you should go
and then my boyfriend had to like
take him with him to the mall
because he was going there and so
he like took the gun he took
the friend to the mall
just like depression like get em out
it was like yeah i don't i
don't understand it and then there was
another like there was a point where
he got mentioned offhandedly like coming to
stay again or something and i just
was like silent what looks like that
was the most annoying you didn't do
anything helpful you didn't leave my place
was very small so it's like we're
just staring at
each other and how long was it
we didn't know each other that well
um like a few days like probably
five days or something that's really like
that's crazy you moving that mike by
the way so i can see you
better
yeah
how's the ah yes you do it
liam gallagher oh i at the bank
yesterday and this woman was talking oh
well it was depositing money ah this
gets better and this woman was talking
to the cashier or whatever like can
tell her teller teller like she as
if she sees him all the time
she's like so how are you
like but it was very like what's
been going on kind of thing and
then but they had no information about
each other so i was like maybe
they don't but she was just saying
in so casually and then she starts
talking about like how do you like
your job and he was like oh
it's fine like it's a job right
well i work in payroll at sag
and we get in like i see
people's checks sometimes and she's
like you know liam neeson and he
was like no and she was like
you know liam neeson he didn't take
any he's like oh yeah i know
she's like he had a he had
a timecard come in for five million
dollars i was like this guy's got
money i was like whoa
i guess there is no banker client
privilege right that was i thought so
crazy to just say secondly it's like
duh like well yeah of course huge
movies i'm not shocked by that i
saw that was in the disaster artist
there's a scene where um seth rogen
goes to cash his check from tommy
wiseau and they and the banker said
yes brian huskey yeah and he's like
oh yeah that guy's got a ton
of money we don't know where it
goes right and i'm thinking so we
are gonna happen in real life too
that sounds like yeah i guess i
was wrong yeah it was so surprising
to me i was just like that
seems rude but also found it interesting
and i'm sharing with all of you
i grew up in co-op went into
deposit something from the office at the
bank
she was only office
yes like a check from the office
it's it down there the the show
the off that's exciting i mean i
guess i forgot that was like the
first big her first big break like
so long ago she went she went
into deposit at the bank at universal
where you know the office is in
everything and the woman took a look
at and said what is
what does this from the office and
she's like wow it's um it's a
tv show just like i've never heard
of it and she goes whoa bad
she goes who's in it and she
goes ah steve carell just because steve
carell from the forty year old virgin
has a television show and check waxy
because i've never heard of it
it's like she would have heard of
i'm steve girl superfan i would know
everything he's done and this is like
four years into the office that's insane
yeah um i'm all business when i
go to a place i don't like
the chai go to the atm may
be when you you will pee yeah
exactly i really don't like to talk
to them or have them think about
like how much money i'm putting in
or when we're looking
at my account and all this so
i don't like the the face to
nayar i went to the denver yesterday
i don't mind that although i have
nothing in a bank in such a
long time i do everything via everything
electronically i went to deposit all checks
i'm we don't care
you get your food stamps mean why
give them the usual place
chick actually means are you gonna say
wait i want to hear everything i
will mail checks in to home your
business through my account and yeah oh
i still do it all myself well
good for you i can i'm john
too much coming in
it's just i'm inundated with two sent
checks
that's why he says we haven't let
him tell you smirking lie deposit checks
for one penny i don't care yeah
i think my feeling is that the
company is going to get all of
the pennies that nobody deposits and then
they get more money from the superman
three theory what's that that's the it's
the half
sent it's the plot of superman three
where they it also went into office
space but no stole it from superman
three where they embezzle the half cents
or the pennies they get left over
and it ends up being millions and
millions of dollars highly plot of superman
three this kind of real lex luther
plan robert vaughn plays for a different
villain
but they stole it for office spaces
see i think maybe they even mention
it that they still owe office
how will the home is three superman
get mixed up in this embezzlement plot
richard pryor is part of it brad
explains it explains our books are looking
weird we better call those perfectly
universe
but this ah
it's super bad news here hey vish
it was just makes it wait what
was the story yeah five minutes ago
oh so just i don't like talk
like talking to the person i went
to the dentist yesterday and the everyone
wants to just make small talk so
how's your day and it's always like
did you have trouble finding us i
got asked if i had trouble finding
them five times
because i just didn't want to get
like i'm there just open my mouth
and do something maybe they think they're
a secret place that's true i had
a dental hygienist who went on on
a like this was the last time
i was there about her divorce she
was going through but i loved oh
you like prefer that over so many
other like small talky things i'd rather
someone just be like oh it's so
crazy my kids hate me right now
i should just go
going on i was like wow i
guess so i will say i don't
like it i think because i don't
like when i get a haircut because
it slows them down um there was
a there was a woman i went
in and got a haircut from that
talked that would stop the haircut and
then just like tobacco away from me
yeah i had a guy guy do
that long
when he would stop cutting my hair
and step around and just just to
be like what do you do here
yeah hanging out so the haircut i
don't have unlimited time like you schedule
a haircut hair cut it's like twenty
minutes for food this is not like
a seesaw or oh i still like
what's up my haircut will take like
an hour i don't want to add
extra time to that
yeah yeah i'm gonna have exploited it
took i think it for a twenty
minute haircut it took an hour and
fifteen minutes i was like i can't
and then i went back and there
it was it was one of those
things where you know whoever stops the
previous haircut gets the next person on
the list and there were there were
ten people and i just saw her
and i was like it can't be
her here and she called my name
i was like god damn it
yeah and she did the whole thing
again and just took another hour and
a high recently got my hair done
at drybar where they just wash your
hair and dry it and then like
style it it was for an event
and normally it should take like forty
minutes it's a quick thing and the
guy the second i saw him i
knew it was gonna be bad because
he had like really weird like
yes like the acid wash wash um
just like really crappy jeans acid wash
here
i was judging his outfit it was
really weird and it was just like
ok this guy's from like the country
he just moved here and he's not
gonna know what's going on he's a
country man you really seem like that
like he kind of was like whoa
yeah lady it was like not hip
to the salon was doing and then
he washed my hair and then he
he took he took an hour and
a half just to dry
dry my hair when was not knows
that he was blowing on it he
was like standing now pulling at oxfam
night cares like always surprisingly thick to
the people doing otherwise like oh it's
more hair than i thought was gonna
be but so it takes a little
longer anything but it was almost like
he had never dealt with that in
his life
just like he was saying like going
through each piece and to the point
i started like panning zombie late and
i eventually was like how much longer
it's gonna be and he's like five
minutes nothing visits like suddenly done i
was like i'd been there for so
long it was driving me crazy and
i didn't want to ask any well
yeah i mean because it's the rudest
question like are you sure i've been
here so many times it's never
taken have you ever done a pair
and you're sure you know how to
do what you do benefit of this
place is that you go it's like
in and out you think this just
like that my favorite burger place yes
you think it was set you for
calling me yeah oh oh do you
think this is a catch me if
you can situation while he's trying to
fuck with me was the craziest pilot
monster he's an impostor
apply it you know could have been
like a jamie kennedy experiment type oh
so with no payoff yeah yeah nobody
comes out the end you're not like
mad and they put like a bad
review online that happened to a friend
of mine she was part of a
prank show she got hired she was
is still an actress sort of but
um she she got hired to do
a
prank show at an audition um so
they set up a whole fake audition
for actors to come she knew what
it was she knew what it was
so she was hired to be annoying
in the audition room oh right so
she she was doing all the stereotypical
like annoying actor things that people do
and in this in this room and
then the trouble was
was they they never ended up airing
the show they never told the people
involved that it was a fake oh
audition for a prank shows so she
would see them at auditions for years
after that and people would alienate her
to the point where she would go
up to people and say hey i
think you recognize me from all
four points from a prank show that
i was on i was i was
told to act that way too and
where people will be like huh sure
you were told to act that way
and that audition oh my yeah wow
just like ruined her kind of audition
see i don't i don't like pranks
yeah i think it's not they're not
right
on this one yeah ah okay oh
ooh ooh not a joke okay i'm
sorry no story ah hey i might
have talked about this before but i
had to do i was part of
this like i said this show should
be part of talked about this before
it was part of this install i've
tried to tell us that too i
i was part of this web series
for fox that never aired but it
was like one of my first jobs
here and was really exciting and a
lot of great people were like thomas
mildish and um brendan johnson and it
was like really funny and fun marc
evan jackson was in it and we
were like the best time and then
we had to do this thing where
we would go we're supposed to be
like people who worked at fox wearing
competent that was kind of like the
idea and we had to go to
like the tcas and do interviews with
people like when they were doing the
press circuit and be like characters asking
them dumb stuff for like part of
the web series so factors like interviewing
them like we already like your entertainment
douglas oh okay but you but
like you work for but they knew
that they knew what we were doing
and but then like we had to
you know what i mean it's it
was because they were in on it
the failure early early early and they
didn't all love it you know people
yes it's a waste of time which
of course it was special because you
never saw it um and i remember
entering everyone on all the new shows
on fox and it was just so
it was one of those
these days where you interview the simpsons
yeah yeah and they weren't great ah
what about the jacksonville jaguars it was
all bunch of people that i've actually
like matt now like nelson franklin like
people who are really nice too and
stewie was there um but it was
the family guy himself your boss stewie
stewie was their dues their bribe
ah i just think it's so weird
when you have to like be like
i'm an actor as well i'm like
yeah like i'm doing something dumb and
you have to go with it and
it's i'm getting paid two cents and
i've never been comfortable with that like
man on the street kind of comedy
where it's like go out and talk
to people and just like it only
one thing with nittai
asha lucero for a pilot i did
out on hollywood boulevard and the the
the game of it was that we
had a long list of questions that
we would ask people ah questions like
who is was your idol growing up
who's the greatest ah who's the who's
the worst person ever in hisd
eatery and then we were going to
mix up their answers in the editing
so it would be like who was
your idol growing up adolf hitler you
know and we got out there on
hollywood boulevard started with the first person
in the first person said oh i
see what you're doing you're mixing up
our answers where in the editing like
basically said exactly bargain dune we're like
ah
next person oh my god just ruined
i hated though because for a while
every single show that i worked on
people like could there be a prank
element people love that i had to
do a man tuesday no no not
that people like people who make people
think people yeah yes i had to
do a magistrate a timer show people
think people
i love it i did a man
on the street commercial for sierra mist
and that never aired and it was
painful standing on in santa monica on
the boardwalk like making people try things
and then i don't even know remember
what like the bit was what people
trying see ships yeah it was like
different drinks zip yeah and then they
had to like say what they thought
about it but then the guy was
doing it with was like this is
a shit show he was like talking
shit to this he was like he
was like going off about how bad
it was going and i just was
like looking at him and be like
yeah like i didn't say anything i
don't know how i knew not to
and then the director counties like the
the the companies in the van and
they can hear you and everything you
said they just heard you say it
was a shit
jumping in when i was like wow
and i was just so happy i
hadn't said anything to take did he
did they keep him on yeah so
hard to roll record and then we
never ever air he has to go
to every commercial sensei you probably remember
say that when i am not to
talk with mike on though now wow
yeah less than i was like oh
next shop it's something that i still
struggle with it's hard to always wonder
is anyone really listening and sometimes i'll
say something and be like i don't
care for her personal not even about
the show i remember once on bang
bang i was like now you're sure
you're turning
the mikes off when people step off
the set and the guy in our
sound person for whatever however many episodes
it was just like i of course
i wouldn't do that and then at
a certain point whenever actors was on
sat and i heard him going to
the bathroom i'm like yeah say yeah
i'm like now you will right outside
the bathroom tenure like the ones that
do you got a drum
hey we have to take a break
we'll be ready
they want him back to go back
well mac welcome back welcome bay have
a story about the microphone thing i
had mine worked on a tv show
where the creator
of the show ran the show was
famous for um listening to the peoples
the actors off camera conversation i got
and then incorporating it into the script
like turning like turning it against this
and so my god yeah it feels
like a tv show plot
like yeah so they wow and you're
gonna did you tell me this or
tell a read about it because i
felt like i read about some situation
i'm sure there's more than one crazy
person right right where where it's st
where the actor started reading the script
and going wait a minute i said
this backstage and i don't we haven't
talked about okay this is something i
read yeah okay so we so so
what were his conversations included in the
know it would be it would be
um are you talking with my friend
yeah you have to wait i'm talking
about shaft the doctor was a woman
shut your mouth i can dig it
the um yes it was the the
guy of the show runner would ah
if he was like displeased with the
person he would take something ah like
kind of embarrassing about the actor and
make it that is mass dialogue yes
ne nasty man is demented that's too
easy i'd be so upset yeah wow
yeah i mean people when they would
talk on set they got
they got used to like tapping the
microphones too but i always just unplug
it now yeah i don't even trust
turning it off i always hate that
watching a television show there's a point
it usually happens late in the first
season where the writers run out of
ideas and so they get to know
the actor's talents and incorporate it into
a show yeah yeah yeah well somebody
starts singing on show yeah for like
oh they start breakdancing yeah we found
out he broke that's like saved by
the bell that's what slater started break
dancing like slash ballet oh we're like
he must have they must have known
he did this did you think did
you think those guys on saved by
the bell we're like good looking guys
zach yeah zach but slater had the
way
just hair i didn't like this girlfriend
mullet was better this is not for
me i mean what's the difference between
him and screech really well a lot
really huge tell me they just didn't
like the same guy to me okay
totally honest totally honestly if when you
got to l a okay the your
first day
l a is usually honest if you
met screech and he seemed like a
normal guy and you're like oh wow
he's actually seems kind of normal would
you have gone out with him say
you weren't with your boyfriend no
huh what if he had a great
personality no
what did he was handsome if he
was a whole different thought what did
you what what are you what have
you is a completely different person okay
so i found out that screech was
played by zach oh yeah what yeah
okay why like your amazing actor what
if screech was played by the actor
who played zack yeah i mean okay
so you go out with screech their
you admitted it yeah she loved screen
she's
ah do you have any sort of
crush ah from watching tv or whatever
the you actually have met since you've
been out here huh
wow yeah well i mean i i
got to work with mario lopez and
i was genuinely really exact that was
very very exciting and he was very
nice um i'm trying to think of
there's anyone else like that though the
i mean i i feel like there
are people i didn't have a crush
on them but i was excited to
work with them i worked with julio
white
a lot of my like people from
when i was growing up vertical of
his show are oh yes he was
writing the speech i mean the screen
a lot of people get sufficiently a
white urkel a family matters not everyone
though not everyone something well yeah it's
it's a popular theory though
i once i don't know ah right
like maybe cool urbanize third date or
something like that we went to the
mtv awards because i did these commercials
were trying to show off
i mean it was yeah you wanna
get drinks oh it's the mtv awards
no i just you know it's fun
to go you go to the part
of course it's fun i love that
so so i did these commercials with
lisa kudrow who was hosting that year
and so they gave me one ticket
and then i was like can i
bring someone and they gave me a
different ticket but it was like totally
far away
um and so they said ok you
can try to sit together but if
the people who own those seats come
ah you know one of you is
gonna have to move and so i
was like don't worry don't worry i'm
sure that whomever i talked to um
i can talk them out of you
know i will just give me stressing
or whatever i was to lose a
little stressful
but but i was like you know
how these things are i'm also makes
you look like a weasel yeah well
get in there cool i knew the
situation so i was laying a lot
to be i was like fine i
was like hey scenario separated and it's
yeah yeah yeah it was like but
don't worry whoever whoever seat this is
you know i'll try to talk him
out of it and then suddenly eliza
dushku comes up to our row and
i was so ready
the two i go this year see
yep okay see you later yeah and
did you see a later
does your see rednecks oh yeah i'll
stay here
i never worked with a crush i
never worked with a ah or even
men i don't think anybody that oh
well
when i was a kid the only
time i ever went to um like
a sci-fi convention i went to a
went to a science fiction yes i
think o c you know the lingo
sir yeah yeah i didn't know what
you were talking about yeah science fiction
thank you um i went to a
doctor who convention because i was a
big fan of the original show when
i was a kid and
did you figure out his name never
did never did mr clarke it's turns
us just dr clark dr josh clark
how would be the best episode of
that show ever so i would watch
it now with that new doctor i
love her yeah jodie jodie whittaker yeah
we've been watching ah church know i've
i saw some projects but now we've
been watching know then you've seen that
it's all about mom or dad i
don't watch broadchurch milan
i think it's so boring but i
so disagree it's insane okay but i've
been watching his seasons of darkmoon co
watching his david tennant yes yes go
ahead well there there was this character
on the original show ah named leila
and she was ah ah from like
a savage planet and she
yeah or like like a fur bikini
it kind of i mean it was
it wouldn't be it was the most
bigot it was the most obviously in
their bones the table
it was a white motor split it
was the most overtly sexual they ever
got on that show and even if
you look at it now you're like
yeah okay it's not like i'm fairly
modest i've seen some of that shit
yeah but it but at the time
i mean this is why they would
cover table legs oh yeah because you
would go insane yeah fuck a table
right why does you
just never at the time you would
never see anything any skin on tv
so to see it in the victorian
era they used to cover table legs
with likely they will be like carved
you know so intricately and it looked
at that says you'll do suggest you
look too much like a bare leg
that he wiped foreigners from my wow
that's an urban legend hell
i don't know i repeated that so
many photos so high it's one of
my favorite cover it where like it
was like put doilies in the house
like a dress yeah like a house
that's so weird or like a long
tablecloth basically these things you know there's
your sign these microphone logs microphone stands
are fucking drive i'm increasing the talks
you
oh
um so i went to this convention
yes and you saw her yes she
was one of the one of the
people and she you know from the
show she was the only actor from
the show there was like a writer
and her yeah and so i waited
in line to get her to sign
did you know she was going to
be there and that's why you went
yeah that's dirty little nasty fellow yeah
i was an ass
a little fellow was there anyone you've
been really starstruck by
like oh yeah so many people act
weird i somebody that unexpectedly i was
so taken with what's mary steenburgen wow
i made her for something her she's
she was just like i fell in
love with her i never like disliked
her anything and i always thought she
was good in everything
but i interviewed her and there was
just something about her that i was
just so taken with her well i
think that's kind of funny because all
of my people that i've been starstruck
by are never people i would think
i would be yeah and i meet
the one of my dad so can't
say anything normal paul reubens i think
i was oh yeah so it's it's
so i brought this up on my
phone because it's so crazy to me
i was very starstruck by paul reubens
the first time i interviewed him and
then i had him on the tv
show and have seen him around so
many times then he texted me like
a holiday card oh which is so
funny to me it's so normal no
it's not oh
ah he just said that to me
with the happy holiday
it was just a tree with the
tv on i was like whoa casual
let's not describe it exactly oh no
i won't say what it is but
there's something on tv that shot up
pretty cold
but it's so funny to me that
ah you know it's one of those
things where you go oh man if
i had known when i was like
this so weird yeah yeah i felt
i probably have told you this but
i felt that way when i met
garry marshall which was really surprising i
never really thought i cared about him
and i met him and i got
so red and i have a picture
with me and my boyfriend mike and
gay
a marshall together and it's like i'm
bright red in it who do you
like better gay marcia
rip
we have to take a break
yeah alright where's the duke come out
where's the dude see it
stumbled out a bit and you don't
get in law itself ambition yawn and
stretch and try to come the lie
liddy out or three drafts out
yeah i'm lost by then out on
the street the traffic starts work oh
i can't while she was hey welcome
back by the way with the music
okay with the music i knew all
the words okay but if i tried
to do it now i can't do
out on the street
blood starts pump pump in something something
ah the traffic starts with folks like
me on the job from nine nine
to five working nine to five whoa
way to make a ah get in
by it's all taking and no giving
they just use ya
mind and they barely gave you credit
it's a nerve to drive you crazy
if you let hey ah okay so
that's our nine to five chunk lauren
you got that out of the way
game here you have a feature now
this is a feat which features a
teacher it's it's called christmas fine
out who game
christmas find out but i am updating
if it's not just christian t-shirt so
you have a purpose to find out
who christmas find out okay you have
christmas find out who gets your paper
ready and i update some of these
questions and you will write the answer
was going to say it out loud
yeah just listen to find out who
gays
questions things like has never done this
or has in this and you say
who do you think is most more
law who has done the thing christmas
find anyway and what are we supposed
to find out who game and then
just find out who game christmas find
out who gave i'm gonna read you
the questions everyone's going to write down
their answer and then at the end
we'll go through them then we'll say
who's done what we all how to
win
don't want to win the most right
we've all started treating each other like
patient like we're patient parents like i
just have to let him get this
out and then the case so here's
ah christmas find out i looked at
the thing theirselves ms find out who
hey kevin um thanks for having me
this dryer
race marker but i'm not going to
use it to write on paper
idiot so wait hey ya i was
calling you an idiot thank you do
we can we vote for ourselves yeah
okay if you're the one who's most
likely why are you filling it out
before i'm making up new questions because
one of them was has been to
bethlehem and i don't want to ask
yeah oh i don't want to ask
that i just don't want to know
i'm just trying to help some other
wife i sent it a friend of
mine have been to bethlehem
i was diz gusting thank you kevin
i love you oh thank you alright
okay so ready yep
ok name the name of name the
person on your paper who you think
best suits the statement number one has
never had a white christmas christmas find
who gains christmas find out who gave
number two has celebrated their birthday in
another country
oh okay number three i returned a
gift for my significant other family who
who's never done that know who has
who had waited like you got there
not all nevers oh you've got to
pray hard so who's who's most likely
to have returned to yes everyone now
what about the first two didn't you
understand
and those guys are sentimental and what
okay i've gotta gotta gotta go
but i guess i don't answer um
okay number four has ridden an elephant
number five yeah do we do we
have to pick a person ah no
you could say none but it's fun
if you say yeah we gotta say
it was almost like well that's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna say who's
most like that's what world yes so
even so if it's one word i'm
pretty sure they didn't do it i'm
still gonna say that this i think
this person is the most likely that's
fine paul
i've number five who is most likely
to get lost very easily christmas find
out who came in number six who
is most likely to have yelled at
a neighbor definitely worn number seven who
has been to spain
none of our silliness number eight who
is cried on the subway line
number nine who has peaked at a
present before christmas
number ten who still has v h
s tapes
paul used to steal on songs okay
so now let's go through them number
one who has never had a white
christmas i would say scott i would
say scott i said myself even though
i've had one but only one yeah
only where were you ah minnesota okay
so everyone gets a point number two
who has celebrated birthday in our country
i said scott i say
said lauren who oh think i have
weight who hasn't or who has see
i knew you didn't know i didn't
know he didn't he thought who's never
done this i'm revolting okay oh did
you put yourself down for myself
i have yes where were you in
france oh i thought that because we
traveled on your birthday last year that
maybe you did that off huh what
was the what was the occasion to
travel to france just vacation was this
urine cool yes yea road bikes running
you around her diagram yeah um i
was like jealous cause i was like
i never
were did that i've been to paris
but yeah it was great you did
my show logo not after that and
the location you gave for the probe
was underneath the little tower that's exactly
um okay who has returned to gift
for my smaller and like i yes
actually huh i've wanted to i didn't
i my first boyfriend would give me
horrible gifts sorry but i never
ever return them because they were always
from like weird places he gave me
like a hawaiian shirt one time in
our wow but i sky wow i
have million times okay so i get
a point way even though we both
agree that you're more likely to i
think if you if your your answer
is correct than your right weight from
a significant meaning meaning
a person who hated we oh so
a person it's not a family person
a person you know consider family significant
other yeah that's true does your dad
or significant do you look your dad
for i just ran a whole damn
fucker article on that on my dad
that was about a girl who fucks
the car weight
and it was only came out yeah
if someone re posted it but it
was like this girl who met her
dad after not knowing it's really there's
my boner again yeah okay huh i
don't know who gets a point for
them we both do okay who has
written an elephant
i put what numbers this sorry for
i felt lauren i put lauren too
and i know i haven't oh yeah
but i was a kid ah the
circus is there yeah where were you
brought up from the crowd no we
got to stick around after like i
guess around half the show i feel
like right now the i p meeting
i don't think anything like
cost extra but i was allowed to
do it we're yeah we all went
on that one yeah um who gets
what is most likely to get lost
easily anymore and i said paul i
send me i almost said you paul
i'm not really because i always will
use my gps yeah but because paul
didn't drive for a long that was
my that was my reason
little reasoning but so you don't get
a point i don't get it because
i heard a joke said lauren for
everything else yeah okay well great okay
number six who is yeah lauren who
do you say i say me i
have i have two
i've never yelled why did you yell
at your neighbor we both we all
get a point this is a horrible
story okay my my mother had just
died and i came back from the
ah from the funeral and i had
i lived in this um in this
nice little house that i was
renting and next store was kind of
like a small apartment building just a
few apartments and this one guy a
lot of times i think he would
either fall asleep with his tv on
or he would leave the house with
his tv on for solo or something
or maybe just wash always always at
night and always at night and so
i am anyway
or ceo
yeah it was always our signal and
so i was ah you know i
just come back and i was getting
in bed with janie we had been
going out for like a year at
this and you got in bed with
her yeah look alright i put all
that religious stuff behind me years ago
and i'm not going to apologize and
see you're hugging and smooching
yeah that's always seemed to do and
so this so this it's like the
outside of my bedroom window is this
window that's like slightly above and this
movie is just like blaring you know
some action movies so it's a lot
it's a lot of gunshots and car
crashes shit like that very good
and so far i'm like calling to
the guy to turn the tv down
there's just no response and i'm with
someone with whom you'd interact i now
know i never used to shouting never
knowingly seen this person i've no idea
who it was and so i was
really still so emotional i just law
lost it i'm screaming at the top
of my lungs turn ya fuckin day
they die out like screaming and nothing
is happening and it's freaking janey out
and you know and i realized like
in the moment like okay i know
i'm i know this is happening because
i'm in an emotional state because imo
mom just died but it was like
i didn't know what to do with
myself and i didn't know how to
there was i didn't know like even
if i went over to that building
like how do i met you this
sounds yeah yeah and so nothing happened
as though nothing happened eventually eventually the
tv got turned off or i went
and slept on the couch or something
i don't know but it was it
was bad that's really bad
who did you yell out i yelled
at my neighbor in the last place
i lived um i had just moved
in there and there was a whole
system with trash cans that you had
to pull them down the driveway and
sigh oh right yeah i know and
it was so fucking annoying and i
was like whatever i don't care i'm
not even like i think on the
firm
first day i moved in i might
have thrown some stuff into my neighbor's
trash can or something like i was
just throwing out a bunch of things
and whatever and my neighbor like kind
of was like that's mine like she
made a point about it and so
i was like okay so i never
did it again i don't even know
that i did the first time but
i never did again and then she
one time and it was i was
becoming a thing i could tell it
whatever was happening with the trash was
like her focus and it was really
annoying to her but i just did
my own thing i only use my
trash cans i never touched anyone else's
then one night she banged my door
ash and she's pulling the trash cans
down the driveway and she pulls one
of them this extra one halfway down
and she goes
you've been throwing trash in there you
need to pull it out and go
no i haven't and that was like
i just i know that i haven't
done that and she's like yes you
have so you said you need to
take it down and then so i
put my shoes on and i went
outside and i dragged all the way
out and i said
yeah i always i pulled it out
and said i didn't put anything inside
this trash can i never will i
only use mine were gonna end she's
like well somebody did somebody just said
well now it's gonna get emptied out
and then i'll never anything it again
and will never have had this conversation
again and she was like so like
she couldn't take it and it was
like we had this whole like thing
and then she started
like one night i came home and
she was painting a white number or
unit number on the bin and i
almost one got painted online but i
was like this is just your out
of your ma i'm not putting shit
in their names a trash can okay
but i don't care it puts put
anything you want inside mine i don't
go far i'm not inspecting it i
don't care if i still have room
i'm from my trash i don't care
if it's like if i'm going to
throw my trash out there's just all
your lowering somebody else's dress i don't
know who was doing it but it
wasn't me but i was like i
yelled at her and then we never
had to interaction basically never talked again
but it was awkward forever okay can
i tell you to oh yeah lauren
yeah i need to get this in
this is the story about um we
had when janey and i lived in
los felix we had these neighbors across
the street that um had moved in
you know that we've been living there
like a couple of years and they
moved in and it was like this
young couple and they would have not
pay
parties but they would have like another
couple over their house parties and they
was sorry that's my old roommate that
was okay let's get into that because
i said so i joke from your
old remains so we they would what
they would do was when they were
hanging out
they would keep their front door open
because they'd like go out and smoke
on their porch or whatever and they'd
be blaring their music and they would
blair it so they could hear it
outside when they would go outside and
so i was now being the guy
who's going across street in his pajamas
saying because you could you just close
your door you don't have to turn
these
but just close the new app in
the back yeah i went out there
in a red union suit i of
course i had my cowboy house in
yeah with lab open i found that
out later of course but i went
they were all laughing and they were
they were always really nice and they
would close the door and it happened
so many times that eventually i was
like i there has to be some
other way to prevent this
from happening right now to keep being
the person yeah and and also so
they don't keep doing it so i
this all of a sudden just occurred
to me i'm going to brett i'm
gonna leave them a bottle of wine
and a nice note saying i will
give you a bottle of wine a
month if you will just remember to
keep your door closed wow music and
a couple of days went by hundred
didn't hear anything i was like ooh
maybe
that wasn't a good idea and then
they eventually wrote me back and said
i'm so sorry we've been disturbing you
you don't have to do this we
will try to remember we we used
to live in laurel canyon we did
not have neighbors oh first so we
got used to doing this i apologize
you know but thank you so much
so that's a nice way to handle
yeah and they didn't like
amy one more time i like trimming
people to it's so because it's so
satisfying i dare to say and it
gets results as much as i i
it stresses me out to think of
yelling at someone the i'm so proud
of myself when i do it like
when it's dessert when you stand up
for yourself like yes i don't care
about this absolutely yeah
yeah i don't like it i always
think to myself i should de-escalate the
situation well then i spent the rest
of the time i living i was
living there thinking that she hated me
in the all the neighbors bonded with
her and they all hated me because
like they would be talking in the
driveway to altogether and i was like
stay like her like i couldn't believe
that like it was like two years
and i was like but i would
never be the person who'd be out
there talking anyway so
i'll check can i tell you one
time a de-escalate of the situation where
i was in new york and i
was flying somewhere pizza for some gig
i i'd had the pizza there and
i was like that's all i needed
to do i was flying somewhere else
pizza so i went to new york
it was with some key you do
this what's a meal
the mention of pizza you like make
your mouth started to form
stay out of new york city um
get around pi it was what i
saw as some gig where it was
like i was on two different airlines
but i didn't realize it because somebody
whoever was hiring me a book the
flight so i was flying on one
airline to the gig and flying back
at another airline i thought it was
both the second airline so i show
up at like delta one was supposed
to be at amerock
second and i so i realized like
i'm in the wrong place and i
go up to the counter and i
say you know ham i'm in the
i don't know what's going on you
know and she looked at my ticket
with it yeah you're in you're in
the wrong terminal you never gonna make
it or something like that like something
really dismissive i'm not helpful and i
was like yeah
and i was like are you gonna
are you gonna help me out and
she went hey don't yell at me
and i said well you gotta help
me out here what am i supposed
to do and that she immediately calmed
down it was like a very it's
a very east coast thea of like
this just how people and i'd forgotten
that but it's like that's how people
talk to each other
you know and it's like as soon
as i did that like it was
she was just very kind fucking help
me i like sad story about the
shoe like the the person who fixes
shoes that you have to yell at
oh my god the her name is
quinn sutherland yeah it was it was
ah it was a it's such a
great thread on twitter yeah yeah about
this this place she goes to she
repaired this guy just yell
oops it everybody else is everybody so
she started yelling back and he respected
yeah it's like yeah alright come on
yeah i love that one it was
the best were you the person when
you were on big bang who are
security guard ah came out and yelled
at you yeah yeah yeah yeah like
you drove on yeah you it says
wait by the security thing yeah but
and this is the
the twentieth time you've been on the
show yeah and you wait for fifteen
minutes he doesn't show up so then
you start driving through and going to
into the parking spot security guard comes
out and goes whoa whoa whoa hey
man you're supposed to wait by the
thing what are you doing and you
and you yelled at him you said
well i'm sitting here for fifty minutes
and look you have a plate lunch
that you went to
okay he goes oh right huh collodion
here the whole fucking i use only
his lunch but he is like disappear
like a cartoon playoff food yeah and
he just debate you yelled at him
he was like yeah yeah like crazy
huh okay let's finish the game like
alright okay um sorry where
or whatnot and has been to spain
i put scott i put lauren i
put lorne because i knew it was
not miserable i've never been there but
i want to go there so i
think because we both said you yeah
just like how you know i am
been to spain i just i don't
know why i would know it i
know you i'm kinda new you both
happen to be on it i almost
went yeah
i almost want wants to oh i'll
never go um eight has cried in
the subway lowering myself i for sure
have yeah you guys know no real
i haven't cried on the subway know
i've cried in public before i enjoy
taking the subway so i you didn't
cry i didn't cry out of fear
just having to step on
i mean honestly no i've been drunk
on the subway horse cried on the
subway surprising i haven't cried yeah
i feel like ah when you live
in new york though it's hard enough
that you end up crying somewhere that
yeah want to cry it's trustee um
nine has peaked at a christmas present
before christmas scott i put paul
ifa lauren i never would i never
wi never have and never would i
think i did when i was a
kid when i was a kid i
used to sneak i used to figure
out where my parents were hiding them
in their closet i remember looking at
them i remember looking like oh where
whereas a r yeah not gonna look
knowing i would see i
yeah i would find out what i
was getting wow i feel like i
definitely looked at one like i can
remember i have the memory of like
carefully mailing paper you know to see
is the is this box going to
look like the thing that i want
to ah i see i hate knowing
anything in advance i love surprise
present i don't want to know anything
about any movie i'm gonna see me
too yeah i feel like i just
don't want to know i'm not that
another way anymore like i totally like
i don't even like presence yeah i
love a surprise gift but i think
christmas care about that so he's like
i got you this thing and i'm
like oh okay like he gave me
one of my presents before christmas
and i was like alright so who
gets the point whoever said scott okay
i did alright you got it okay
not our ten ah still has v
h s tapes i said paul i
said paul yeah that's true i do
nice i said you do i might
have one
which was yeah you have to say
my girl to horny miku
no i don't know it's not porn
either i don't know what it is
but probably you don't know already because
i know you probably have some at
my parents' house okay stay and whatever
alright i'm gonna be like embarrassing i
have stuff that's like i have my
high school plays my high school
musical oh yeah john d just taped
from high school that i didn't i
got to transfer those and then i
have some things like early like my
earliest stuff on tv that i would
yeah don gray i have some movies
that just never came out on dvd
are like twenty ninth street i remember
that was a movie that i saw
an indiana when i lived there aesthetic
it was like a christmas movie but
with
a lot of cursing i feel like
danny yellow was wait have you previously
aforementioned to any so he's doing okay
wu transfer your home movies we've done
that now i have a whole box
i want to do but i'm so
afraid to love places you've descended in
i don't like the idea of mailing
now i got one of those machines
that does v h s two disc
and i it's just been sitting in
my garage forever
wow i have yeah i just have
like the camera you chose to dvd
yeah because now you'd have to upgrade
it even more i knew did digitize
who got more than a i've got
eight i got a i didn't keep
track so ah well oh in
oh christmas guy died who christmas find
out who gave christmas find out who
game christmas find out who okay great
let's find out who gave we gotta
go see you next time bye
this has been in year with production
executive produced by scott ackerman chris bannon
and colin anderson for more information and
content visit airwolf dot com